the jurgen experience dude first of all
congratulations on your comeback
i that you know you're a great guy
and when there's someone i like who
loses a bunch of fights in a row and you
get into this skid
it's hot it's hard to watch i can't
imagine what it was like being you
you know to have a young child and to be
dealing with
all this going i mean it's like losing
your top but then
to come back the way you did against
a really [ __ ] tough guy in the sun
sal and get
arguably the ko of the year i mean you
got to be feeling pretty [ __ ] good
i feel great you know back from the
brink back from the brinks i mean
that time in my life that time frame
period and going through that
you know from on top of the world world
champion uh to three fight skid
honestly it feels like a a lifetime ago
i feel like i'm just a different person
um where i was at from there you know
removed and
the things i'm just doing differently
thinking differently you know how i was
able to approach the game picking myself
back up time and time again i mean it's
internet is a horrible place to get get
knocked out on you know
[ __ ] you got the trolls this and that
you know it's
but besides that point you know um just
coming back to that and
having a love for it a lot of the times
i got to the fight and
not to make excuses i was just i didn't
feel myself
i didn't feel like um in the training
and leading up i felt
physically i'm always ready to fight
like flip the switch i'm already
physically ready to fight
i think mentally going into those fights
i was just um
out of body i wasn't i felt like i was
going through the motions you know my
passion wasn't there i wasn't waking up
every day like what's your reason why
i was just trying to find that and i
think the reason why i had so many
people
infiltrated in how i should train or how
i should live or what i should do to get
back there
and really it wasn't nothing that i
needed to learn new
i didn't have to reinvent the wheel it
was just doing the slight edge theory
like getting out of your comfort zone
like
you're doing your sauna sessions like
you're pushing yourself to go in there
and
just be uncomfortable um you know so i
had to go out there and
with that comeback you know i moved to
jersey the training camp out there i
suppose yeah i want to talk to you about
that
i'm a big fan of henry mark henry's a
bad [ __ ]
he's great i love i enjoy him so much
his passion for his love for it he's so
interesting too his crazy codes and the
fact that the dude makes pizza on the
side
dude i was so nervous going out there
because i heard of the codes and
and like you know i was with lance lance
kind of giving me a little
insight on it on everything like damn
codes and i just fight dude like i don't
have really set
things i kind of go off of my instincts
and game plans and
he was trying to you know brief me on it
when i got to the first two weeks
holy [ __ ] we go down to his basement and
he has like pizza scrolls from the
pizzeria
where we have off about 50 things that
we're working on
um before camping so what does he write
them on boxes pizza boxes
pizza scrolls like the just basically
white paper anywhere
you know he's working with 14 fighters
at one time he knows all the codes and
all different kinds of fights too
like he's got zabeet there he's got
frankie it's like
all these different styles yeah
different styles and we'll kind of
you know what i like about that is he'll
try things that's his beat does
it does these crazy double jump scissor
kicks and
spinning you know the russians are
really good at spinning [ __ ] you know so
we threw that into the into the game and
it it's it's you know it was nice to get
that kind of the stuff that frankie's
done and had success over the years
um so we meshed that together um he got
to know me really well
uh we worked you know extensively with
ricardo almeida up there as well
but yeah coach henry is just there's
nothing he's obsessed with winning but
what i loved about him was
the first thing that he said to me um
was that his job is
he's competitive he wants to win at all
costs but his job is to get us back to
our family
and um i watched your podcast with uh
andre ward and he said the same thing
about his trainer
and i once he said that to me and i have
a child now my whole thought process
has changed you know in transition and
they're like i want to be able to be
around for my son's life i want to have
you know um speak to my grandchildren
i'm not drooling you know that's what
coach mark i want you to draw when
you're you know you're 50 60 years old
and i kind of style that fight i can
punch and move i don't have to brawl
these guys
right you know and um just reiterating
the defensive
part of the technical offensive part
with him
is i could go in there and hit a six
seven punch combo
dude he would he would care less he was
like what did you do after you moved
after your head was off your hands was
up like
that he's all about defense and you know
i think he just
helped me out a lot with saying that
like getting me home to my family safe
like that's what i want to do
it's such an important approach to be
defensively sound
and and yet there's so many fighters who
don't think like that at all they just
think about
offense and if you you know
it's it's really like in jiu jitsu like
hicks and gracie
had uh i had a conversation with him
once about jiu jitsu and one of the
things that he said
is that the most important thing is
defense he said because i'm always safe
this is what he said he goes i'm always
safe and he goes in every position i'm
always safe
like he lets guys on his back with a
fully locked in rear naked choke
and he'll start rolling like that he
he's always safe so he never
and that's interesting also i read that
about the donahue death squad
john donahue's guys like you know gordon
ryan and all those guys they'll start in
really bad positions
all the time they train constantly in
bad positions so they're always
defensively sound
and that makes sense with striking as
well so many guys
are so concerned with offense and you
know you've had
so many spectacular knockouts like the
thomas almeida fight
that it's just like you probably just
want to blast guys true
i get i got to like pull the reigns back
sometimes i'm like dude i'm
so amped up just getting there and get
the fight you know like
forget to walk out fit the you know yeah
i'm gonna
i want to get the first blow i want to
get that exchange and then that's when
the fight unravels sometimes i think i
get so amped up that
you know taking it back you know doing
that kind of having defensively sound
sets up your offense yeah and my uncle's
training me my whole entire life
and this is what he said your often sets
up your defense and vice versa
but okay like my offense was so good and
then you get to this point where
you people are breaking down your
footages and your films and you know
your speed and power
you know you have to have that you have
to be defensively sound if you're so
offensive
i'm a forward fighter i can fight going
back a lot of fighters can't go i can
i can fight positional and like you said
about danner's guys
chris holdsworth um has adapted into a
phenomenal coach you know he's
my right-hand guy from martial arts to
the t and he makes us start in horrible
positions
like that when we're dog dead tired and
then get up and we're shadow sparring
each other and going back to the ground
like
really fight simulated things to where
you're feeling uncomfortable in those
positions like
yeah i can go in there and knee wrestle
all day during jiu-jitsu i didn't get
tapped on ain't happening but i was safe
but
i didn't put myself in those positions
when the fight really happens
you have to see how you know your grit
you got to be able to fight off the
hands right off the body trying to go
fight all those bad positions so
you're comfortable or whatever the fight
goes and i feel like that's where i'm at
now i've transitioned into that
fighter i was so green when i got to
alpha male and and a lot of my speed and
power
catapulted me to the top where i have to
kind of draw back a little bit and do
the correctional errors
not reinvent things not do things but
the defensive part of things like
you know i was up and training in jersey
and i knew i had the good head slips and
movements
but some of the slips coach was watching
me i'll get caught on the you know after
first or second i usually get hit with
the fourth punch you know that's a combo
puncher
so i would slip slip and then i would
slip down this way and i would get hit
with the
the jab and every time he's like dude
just bring your hand up a little bit
when you're slipping to the right you're
moving to the right
and i you know how you feel after swear
i'm like dude i feel great i don't have
a headache i'm not getting
my ass kicked like i'm not getting hit
really like my defense has gotten so
um solid working with him and just
constantly
and chris is the same way and my coaches
out and alpha male are the same with
hands up
hands up hands up but i was just at that
point in my life i was just so
aggressive and angry and just we had so
much success
attacking that way at doing that but
this last fight i was honestly
joe when i was you know doing those
faints on the sun sound and coach henry
said hey don't
feel like these veins aren't going to
work like he's defensively sound he's a
great fighter
at that respect keep doing these faints
they will work
i'm fainting this guy dude i'm fainting
i'm fainting he's not really biting he's
not really coming in
but i kept on the faints and we you know
i started catching with some some shots
that i saw and his eyes were hurting him
and then fainted did the tyson too his
overhand right dropped him and i knew
once i had that range and the power and
speed and his timing
that he would come in with something so
uh you know the ko the way you did it
where you dropped your hands and
looked to the side and waited for him to
move oh my god
that was like one of the best walk-off
chaos ever i felt great because the
first round
i kind of had myself to the cage and
coach man he
he'd probably kick my ass being on the
cage like get get off the cage get to
the you know movement more we're
movement fighters you know he made me
um and i know my back was in his cage
but i saw and in the the round was
ending but i saw
a sunset like oh here's my opening i saw
that in that first round and then
the second round was staying off i was
moving i was speeding i'll switch you
know stances
um but towards the end of that i heard
the clappers i'm like i'm back and swell
let him come in i kind of leaned towards
and he kind of like faded on it and then
he chased me down when i
level changed i kept my eye on him and
he threw the hook because he was going
south paul
and i knew like i had to hand my hand on
the cage and know where
my distance was that he was coming with
a kick after i could lean back
i just had my range on my timing and
once right through it man
i knew when i feel it from the hip it
was it was over
two and that that guy is so
[ __ ] durable that's the thing i mean
this guy is so tough and so
so durable for you to catch him and ko
him like this
yeah that had to feel so good catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify watch back
catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience